joining us now is the German ambassador
to the UK Miguel Berger thank you so
much for being with us this morning
um it's been a bumpy few months for the
UK uh shall we say you know partly
because of global factors like inflation
uh partly because of domestic issues as
well and what do you think the UK is
currently perceived from abroad
yeah I would say that everybody is glad
to see that financial markets are now
again more stable but the challenges you
have to described we are all facing them
high inflation Energy prices going up
governments struggling to get the
necessary support for business and
private households so I would say there
is also quite some understanding for the
challenges yeah those challenges as you
say um experienced by countries across
Europe the rest of the world as well and
what do you see as the you know Way
Forward for that
I think we have to be aware that this
energy crisis will not go away after
winter because we will have zero Russian
gas in Europe and Russia has been by far
the largest supplier that means that not
only Germany the whole of Europe UK will
have to get cash from the international
markets and that means for the next one
and a half two years we might face a
situation with high energy prices let's
talk a bit about Ukraine
um shall we because I think the German
Chancellor spoke to Vladimir Putin this
week on the phone uh he urged him to
withdraw troops and to try and find a
diplomatic solution and it's Germany
optimistic about a way out of the wall
we are not yet optimistic we don't see a
fundamental change in the Russian
position
Putin continues this really terrorizing
the civilian population we are very
concerned about that because these
attacks on the energy infrastructure
mean that many people with freezing
temperatures might be forced to leave
Ukraine so we expect another wave of
refugees in the coming weeks so but to
your question no we don't see for the
foreseeable future a willingness to
engage in the Diplomatic solution in the
conversation Allah Schultz also vowed to
continue German support for Ukraine and
there has been some criticism hasn't
there that Germany was a bit slow of the
mark in offering support to Ukraine
perhaps you could have done a little bit
more as some would say in terms of
Military Support as well I think we can
show that you know the different amounts
that countries have spent on weapons and
equipment to Ukraine it's the numbers
just on the left there you can see the
us at the top followed by the EU but
both Poland and the UK above Germany
despite having smaller populations
should Germany do more
I think these figures are not correct
because we have sent many weapon systems
which were written off
so for example the anti-aerial a gay
part tanks which were already been
written off so we can't have them in
this statistic as new tanks so I would
not give too much on it but my feeling
is that we start at the middle a little
bit later than others but in the end if
you look at the amount of weapon systems
especially
Iris T anti-aerial missiles they are
extremely effective 100 of Russian
missiles attacking Kiev the last raid
were shot down so I would say we are
doing all quite well and I guess there's
been action on energy as well in the eu2
where there is obviously more of a
dependence on Russian oil and gas yeah
but this has been dramatically reduced
but let me say on weapons I think the
key issue is that we continue to send
weapons and ammunition and assure
maintenance of the equipment we have
sent over the coming months only if that
happens Russia will understand that they
will not really be able to to defeat
your Ukraine so this is I think the key
challenge for all of us
um before we move on to brexit which I
do want to do um I just want to ask you
a question on China because we've seen
some really extraordinary protests in
China recently
um originally about the lockdown but
also spilling over to
um other issues as well um Chancellor
Schultz announced recently that Germany
is going to try and reduce its
dependence on trade with China that will
be quite difficult to do though won't it
it's a challenge for all of us and I
think the key issue is that we have to
diversify our trade relations so we have
to look at our weaknesses the weaknesses
like for example semiconductors
batteries Rare Earth so we have to
invest in Western production try to
re-shore certain industries but let me
say that we are working in Germany on a
new China strategy and we are
cooperating whether very closely with
the British government which are which
is doing the update of the integrated
review so I would say we are analyzing
together the challenges of China it's
interesting that the UK and Germany you
see is perhaps working together to get a
new sort of strategy on this then yes
and we have to do that I think if there
is one lesson of Russia's war of
aggression is that we have to reduce
dependencies from China
um now there's been lots of speculation
in the UK but Rishi sunx approach to
brexit
um are you optimistic that there could
be some kind of breakthrough uh in the
disagreement about the Northern Ireland
protocol I think that we have now a
different basis for negotiations I see
an openness to engage there have already
been talks and yes I would say I'm
cautiously optimistic because in the end
there is a lending zone for the Northern
Ireland protocols implementation it is
possible to find a solution the
difficult issue is is more the political
on the reaction of the dup the risk of a
of an election in Northern Ireland so
there are many political issues which go
together with it but if we speak about
the negotiation process I would say I'm
cautiously optimistic that's interesting
do you think then that Rishi Cena has a
different attitude a different set of
priorities perhaps to list trust and
perhaps also boss Johnson
yeah I I would say that even less trust
made some steps towards Europe she
participated in Prague at the first
meeting of the European political
community and the first talks were
already under this trust with James
cleverly so um I would say we see in
general a different attitude maybe it
has also to do with the war in Ukraine
that everybody understands that in the
west we have more important challenges
to face and that democracy should work
together and should be able to sort out
an issue like Northern Ireland with the
um you know you talk about the the
threat from Ukraine and Russia but also
obviously we are facing an economic
crisis as well right with energy bills
and given that do you think that there
is a desire both from the EU side but
also from the British side I guess to
have a closer relationship I would say
yes and it has always been the position
of the German government that we want a
relationship as close as possible with
the United Kingdom and yes you mentioned
energy this is a perfect example if we
look at the challenges electricity
supply for the UK in Winter a lot of LNG
went through the UK to Germany to the
center of Europe so energy is a perfect
example of of an area where we should
cooperate to Mutual Advantage there's
been speculation about so-called Swiss
steel which effectively means you know
access to the single Market it would
come with greater contributions to the
EU budget and also more immigration from
Europe as well officially the UK
government has ruled out but I guess
what I'm interested in is would that
even be a possibility it would even be
something that would be on the table
from the European side
I would say that we welcome that there
is a discussion about this kind of we
don't have to go into the details of the
Swiss model but that the government or
parts of the government are thinking
about how to have a better and closer
relationship with the European Union is
something that that we see very
positively
it feels that kirstan is perhaps
reluctant to talk too much about brexit
he of course was a very strong remainer
and would you like to see a stronger
line from labor
I think that's really the decision that
labor has to take but we see also very
positively that labor is willing to have
a very close relationship with Europe
and I think the rest we will have to
leave it now to the negotiations because
if we achieve a solution on Northern
Ireland then this will help also to
develop other areas of cooperation so I
would see the solution of the Northern
Ireland protocol question as a first
step and there will be others then to
follow
um there's a lot to talk about in
independent Scotland here in the UK as
well if Scotland was to vote for
Independence and would they have to
adopt the euro to join the EU
you know I don't really want to get into
okay internal question but let me put it
like that every country that is joining
uh the European Union and we are
currently negotiating with some
countries in the western Balkans know
that they have to introduce the Euro
um interesting um and then just finally
could you see a position in the future
where the UK joins the single Market
very difficult to predict I would say
let's take it step by step
um but in Germany obviously there is a a
lot of interest in having as I said the
United Kingdom as close as possible so
Europe and to Germany uh thank you um
now I'm sorry to bring itself but the
World Cup is of course still going on uh
Germany are out thanks to a winning goal
from Japan against Spain that knocked
you out and there was a pretty
controversial VAR decision uh in the
lead up to that goal that this it was
ruled that this ball didn't go out of
play
do you agree just look at this picture
that the ball didn't cross the line
yeah it seems that the ball was in maybe
three four millimeters but you know in
the end this doesn't matter because
Germany should never have lost the match
the first match against Japan so let me
only say really good luck for the
english team tonight against Senegal um
oh there you go you're going to be
supporting England against
that yeah it will be an interesting
match to watch
um and just finally I just want to show
you uh this picture of the German team
because they were certainly a team who
tried to make their voices heard in
Qatar covering their mouths there to
send a very clear message that they
weren't allowed to I guess show their
um disagreements with some of the
qataris positions on human rights
um were you proud of the German team for
doing this and would you have liked to
see more coordinate in action from
European teams on this yeah let me say I
was really proud of seeing seeing them
because it was a very controversial
discussion about the World Cup in Qatar
as it was in the United Kingdom and
especially this very appalling interview
by the head of FIFA Mr Infantino so I
think if there is one conclusion out of
that is that we should only have this
big sporting events in countries which
respect workers rights and respect basic
human rights that's interesting to hear
you say that so uh family I think many
people would agree with that analysis as
well at uh thank you so much for being
on the program this morning good to have
you here thank you thank you